un día
dios
no sucede
de todo
y hoy ya pasaron 45 días no importa muy
bien
la empresa está en tú
y
es que no estás haciendo una dieta
y esa persona es
la diferencia entre hacer
quizá
como conviertes algo que tú quieres ser
como te conviertes en esa persona que
quiere ser parte de tu identidad
yo soy nada más
entonces
luego tenemos
los otros pensamientos
éramos conscientes
y los dos con acciones
los inconscientes son los que todos que
venimos programados los que
escuchamos
en publicidad
simple
los que
desarrollar a propósito
por una emoción
yo pienso
este pensamiento y esa emoción
me crea se desarrolla
la experiencia
yo realmente creo en eso
es muy fuerte pero no es tan fuerte como
la convicción todavía no es parte de
evidencia
esa presencia
encuentra un pensamiento que desarrollar
y en las que no lo quieren
tu cuerpo
entonces lo tenemos
manzana el sistema incluso en particular
eso es un filtro dentro de todas las
cosas que hacemos de manera inconsciente
consciente
un poco en qué es
cuando hacemos
mientras ves ese audio azul me encanta
te sientas
y así es
y aunque nos promete
y el siete días de la semana estás
pensando
[Música]
s todos las
nos indica temas carros azules la ciudad
es lo mismo cuando una persona más
y cuidados
y nos
no soy más consciente de eso estamos
después
puede usar
empieza a buscar
a continuación
el mundo
entonces yo pienso que soy buenos amigos
ya y haciendo eso
ya vamos descubriendo
news
y así entendía describiendo por el
oficial
y este ciclo
después de darles hijos un montón de
veces
se convierte
la misión
cuando algo sobre la comisión sobre el
pacto
este año pasado
duro
más fuerte
el año pasado con hambre y ganas de
comerme al mundo
m
lleva 20 años
y dije
aquí es
te levantas digital hacemos esta empresa
nivel
pues yo soy de producción
[Música]
y
dirección administración y en tres
ventas en europa
y
una vez
y no vendí nada
y empiezo a dudar en mis capacidades
bien
las velas
y
un sonido
a veces
o tal vez
no es un sábado
yo tengo un pensamiento
es una emoción
l
[Música]
y pasó más o menos
y salida
y una vez
y un mundo en que
tanto pensarlo en tanto recibir su
confirmación
ahora el rey
y eso fue lo que yo tenía persona
en el proyecto
y el reto es el de cambiar todo
[Música]
y
feliz
celebramos
y entonces
ayudando
y me dice
pues hay un movimiento pero
no creo que el anular miento
pero para nosotros
[Música]
no sé
y luego de la emoción
[Música]
y más educación
para verano esas ganas pesadas
con el mundo
en su autoestima
realmente me desconocía
y
bueno un domingo estoy usando el
programa
como más
bueno
y con ese sexto sentido de madre es
normal
hoy me pierdo empecé con ella de obama
no sé
quiero hacer
yo quiere ser un líder de opinión del
mundo
el único semanal
bueno mi socio
sariego
porque con cuatro
puedes descubrir que quiero hacer
y los buenos
[Música]
y
era un buen de la noche
todo en la ciudad
radio
y
empiezo
al pensar meditar a cuestionarme que
estoy haciendo con mi vida
y en el silencio
está bien
que hay en huelva
de la madre
y estaba dejando que en pensamientos y
actitudes de escasez
bien
y bienes que haces lo resolví está claro
para mí
me dice que obren mensaje y mandó mi
cabeza
estoy pensando no no voy a tener el
sábado aquí ahorita el recuadro
entonces
y qué
me costaba un día me cruzaba algo aquí
la casa
y yo como cualquier persona
para la segunda
y yo acababa de comprar toda la comida
de las paradas
seguro demandaba email
d
un poco
lo contrario en todo esto lo contrario a
vivientes
abundancia
en un bar y ahora ni una gota
cuando caigo en esa decisión
y
no
a
y si comparamos la cantina
hola
ninguna diferencia de mi comunidad
y cuando todo eso
pues muy feliz y emocionado llegó con un
instinto táctico
oye
y por qué
de acuerdo con discutir su unidad
y nos vamos
al llegar ahí
mismo a la reciente
entonces
cuando empiezo a
[Música]
voy a realmente
pues hacer a los hombres
estamos hablando de
contra
karim turnos
y lo más importante
y allá
congruencia
entre lo que empiezas y lo que sientes
porque sientes que lo que dices
entonces no está preparando de la noche
201 inconscientemente el hogar
ya no sé entonces vuelvo esto
y la forma en la que programas la forma
de la mente
[Música]
en esa persona que tú admiras esa
persona que hace todo lo que tú quieres
hacer
es
que un pensamiento
tendrían esa persona
solución
ahora eso no es suficientemente fuerte
como en todos los lugares
a continuación
conscientemente empiezo a buscar esa
continuación externa en que tu
pensamiento automoción y tu coherencia
que quiere desarrollar
existe pinos
y después de un montón de cuentas eso
no más
logras
y en cuatro meses
darme cuenta de eso
volviendo
[Música]
se fueron presentando diferentes cosas
ya no nada más
ahora todo es correcto
las ventas de facturas han estado con
hamás así es la vida
y realmente empiezo a lograr ese sueño
que siempre siempre me habla
y luego en otros años principalmente
[Aplausos]